he's Bob Costas Major League Baseball
Network analyst Hall of Fame broadcaster
joining us on the program Bob good
morning how are you hello Dan how are
you I'm now caught up in this whole
kerfuffle between you and mr. Schrager
yeah you know it's sometimes your sample
you know musicians talk about sampling
or borrowing we used to call it stealing
but you know I just we say something on
Monday it ends up on the football
Network on Wednesday and we have you
know we have spies out there Bob we were
journalists yeah you know I was just
speaking before Todd called me I was
just speaking with Bruce kornblatt whom
you know you know NBC and Bruce was
praising Tom verducci's work yesterday
in the coverage of the Hall of Fame
elections and Tom has a particular not
for this he's not just knowledgeable but
he's really a graceful writer and he
wrote this piece about Mariano Rivera
and he said that 11 earned runs were
scored upon him in all of the postseason
appearances that he made fewer runs than
men who have walked on the moon okay
then this morning on a show which shall
not be mentioned they presented that as
if it were stat they just discovered it
happens all the time Dan oh I know it
happens to those of us who are at a
higher level they don't steal from those
who occupy the lower rungs on the ladder
you consider it a compliment and oh I
know we were having fun with but but it
feels like it's okay now you just you
don't have to attribute anything to
anybody anymore right all right when you
guys don't like you guys we're waiting
with your pitchforks as you guys
mentioned that somebody was not gonna
vote for Mariano Rivera you almost
sounded disappointed that there wasn't
some old curmudgeon who said no I'm not
gonna put him on because I didn't vote
for Babe Ruth yeah that's pretty pretty
much it but no commotions that was the
final tally 425 yeses and 0 curmudgeons
but if there had been one or two then we
eventually would have discovered who
they were and they would have to give an
account of themselves but that doesn't
happen all right you know the one
hundred percent what does
100 per set mean if you're Mariano
Rivera and you're the first you're one
of one is he the most perfect player at
his position in baseball like how would
you quantify this yet if at all I think
it shows that there is no argument no
credible argument of any kind to be made
against him next year when Derek Jeter
will go in
perhaps unanimous certainly nearly
anonymous someone could make the case
you or I wouldn't buy it but they could
make the case well if Cal Ripken wasn't
unanimous Jeter plays the same position
then why should Jeter be unanimous I'm
gonna withhold my vote but there is
absolutely no dispute that Mariano
Rivera is the greatest closer in
baseball history you know you could make
a case who's the best player who's the
best outfield that was the best catcher
we might all feel that there's a
clear-cut choice in some of those cases
but there's an argument made for
somebody else there's no argument to be
made for anybody else when it comes to
Rivera's the top closer your phone's
popping a little bit give us a second
yeah Fritzi if you'll jump on with Bob
let's see if we can clear that up a
little bit I was looking at you know
Edgar Martinez I mentioned that the
fourth highest on-base percentage of a
right-handed hitter in the history of
the game Mike Mussina you know you've
seen it was sort of lost in the Clemens
pettite like you just sort of went oh
yeah he won 20 games and then retired I
think two pitchers in the history of
game had done that
Sandy Koufax due to injury retired he
might have gone one 26 or 27 games last
year and then retires and then Mussina
samite won 20 games but I was looking at
me seen his numbers 250 wins and 2,500
strikeouts you know it's a short list of
you know some of these I think these are
guys I'm glad they got in but I think
aside from Mariana you sort of forgot
about how great they were and that even
includes Roy Halladay Bob's back with us
as you were saying Bob yeah my deathless
comments apparently were lost in a bad
phone connection but my point to your
question about Rivera was that let's say
Derek Jeter who's going to get in easily
next year could be unanimous if it isn't
it'll just
a few votes that keep it from being
unanimous and the only possible argument
against him but it is a possible
argument as well if Cal Ripken wasn't
unanimous then I'm not gonna vote for
Derek Jeter because he played the same
position but in the case of Mariano
Rivera
there is absolutely no argument to be
made or anybody else as the greatest
closure of all time you want to argue
Willie Mays and Hank Aaron you can make
a credible case for either one they're
both phenomenally great but there's
absolutely no discussion about anybody
else when it comes to who's the best
closer of all time and I think that
along with changing voting patterns is
what made it possible for Mariano to go
and sweep the board do we have too much
analytics in baseball in some quarters
yes in some quarters it's look if I can
fill you that this guy's war is equal to
somebody who you knew at first glance
was a Hall of Famer well then that guy
is just as good as this guy who's among
the true baseball immortals I think
analytics are really important both for
building teams and making decisions in
the present day and also for considering
players historically and considering
them for the Hall of Fame I'm not saying
they don't count they count a lot but
they're not always definitive they're
not the be-all and end-all and if you
think the whole thing can be decided by
what a computer spits out then I think
you're taking the heart beat out of the
game I know that you guys have talked
about this the last couple of days on
the MLB Network and you're talking about
bonds and Clemens being on the clock and
you know now we have a three-year window
of them trying to get in you know during
their years of eligibility I'm wondering
if a rod will eventually be the first
steroid tainted player known steroid
tainted player into the Baseball Hall of
Fame
well we didn't discuss that on the air
yesterday but a number of the guys and I
won't name them a number of the guys
former players say there is no way that
a-rod will ever get in because he used
peds when there was testing when there
was punishment when everything had been
codified when the dust had cleared with
the steroid era and everybody got what
was going on and so despite the fact
that it's pretty
clear to me that he would have been one
of the greatest players of all time if
he never had anything more potent than a
protein shake he's gonna have a tough a
tough climb you look at Manny Ramirez
now Manny Ramirez was not nearly as good
an all-around player as Alex Rodriguez
what works against Manny is not just the
three failed drug tests but the fact
that he openly quit on two teams no
question about it the fact that he was
an indifferent Fielder and a lousy
baserunner so you can't make a case he
was a great all-around player you can't
make a case it was one of the best
right-handed hitters of the modern era
but the connection to peds plus the
other deficits takes him out of it so
he's not an exact match for a rod but he
did use peds after there were rules in
place and I think the same thing is
going to gonna hamper a rod a bit he's a
better player with better
accomplishments so I'm sure his vote
totals will be higher than Ramirez but
can he get to 75 we'll see Harold
Reynolds said yesterday weren't on the
air but he said look he comes on the
ballot in three years you got ten years
on the ballot you're talking 13 years
out and younger and younger voters who
might not have the same gut feeling
about the steroid era that you and I do
so
a rod has a chance because the stuff is
gonna be in the rearview mirror by the
time his eligibility runs out do you
think buns and Clemens get in the next
three years you know I really thought so
until yesterday Peter Gammons and I were
talking and we both thought weeds had
bonds and Clemens would get at least to
the low 60s and probably to the mid
sixties based on the substantial jump
they took a year ago but they only moved
up two percentage points to around 59
percent now they have three years left
and here are the things that could help
them for players get in plus Fred
McGriff who probably didn't get justice
Fred McGriff comes off because this was
his tenth year of eligibility that's
five slots next year Derek Jeter is the
only player worthy of consideration and
in 2021 there is no additional player
worthy of consideration so that clears
the log jam out and during that period
of time a few more younger voters will
come in and as Tom Verducci pointed out
yesterday those who become eligible to
vote in the last several years are
trending at 85% yes for bonds and
Clements and it's possible we
can't read their minds but it's possible
that some of the old line voters are
gonna come around in the tenth year and
that their thinking was I'm gonna make
them sweat I'm gonna hold my nose and
vote for them in the tenth year but not
a moment before and if those
combinations come together more space on
the ballot more new voters old guys
coming around
maybe they eat over 75 but they're not
gonna get eighty percent or anything
close to it
are we being objective with Curt
Schilling no I've been saying forever
that he should have gone in on the first
ballot Curt Schilling has the best
strikeout to walk ratio of any pitcher
whose career started after 1900 he has a
phenomenal postseason record 11 into the
low er a but also iconic moments on top
of it
pitched well in four World Series three
of which his team won it just and he
finished a second in lee siyoung voting
three times and the only reason he
didn't win one or two is that Greg
Maddux and Randy Johnson won those sigh
Young's that the stuff that he says on
Twitter or the things that rub people
have wrought the wrong way are
completely irrelevant
what matters is what he did on the field
and Curt Schilling should have been in
the Hall of Fame years ago I wonder if
he contributed to MSNBC if he was as far
left as he as far right would he be in
the Hall of Fame oddly I don't think it
would hurt him as much yeah but it's
irrelevant either way oh I know I that's
why it drives me crazy when like I just
look at Curt [ __ ] well I don't agree
with Curt Schilling but I look at Curt
Schilling and I have to be objective I
didn't like Barry Bonds but I have to be
objective when I look at his career or
somebody else who wasn't friendly to me
but I have to just look at this and say
are you a hall-of-famer or not and I
look at Schilling if I said you got a
game to win and you can pick anybody in
the history of the game or let's say
since 1970 Curt Schilling is going to be
on the short list I believe whether you
like it or not and I absolutely you know
there's something to be said about it's
like Jack Morris I argued for Jack
Morris because I said he didn't give a
damn about his er a he went out and
pitched and he pitched in big games for
big teams you know winning championships
and Schilling was that way he
the ball and he wanted to go the
distance and you know there's value in
that he made him not up you know doesn't
have the numbers that match up with some
of these other guys but he's a
hall-of-famer in my book yeah the
numbers don't match up our victory
totals he's just over 200 but the other
numbers the ER a the postseason
performances the strikeout to walk ratio
those are off the chart
yeah Bob good to catch up with you
thanks for joining us as always all
right dad take it easy all right
the great Bob Costas joining us for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]